What is going on guys? Mr. Zinc here.
Welcome back to another video. In
today's video, I'm going to be recapping
the three trades I had in the day. Those
being 303 profit, $52 profit, and $106
profit. I'm going to walk you guys
through why I entered where I did, how I
got the bias that I did, and pretty much
how my entire trading day went. The
first thing that I always do is I go
over to QQQ on Trading View. As most of
you know, this is where I do my charting
and then I do the trading on Project X.
For QQQ, I always start the day with
charting the previous days 50. So, we
have our previous day's high at 10:15.
We have our previous day's low pretty
much at 8:00 p.m. close. Drag that out
to the right. And then we have our
London 50. Our London low was at 6 a.m.
And our London high was at 8:45.
That is our London 50 and previous days
50. That is what I use for entries. I
love having entries at the London 50 and
previous days 50. London high, London
low, previous days low, previous day's
high. Those help a little bit. The next
thing that I did was I noticed that we
are within the previous day's range.
Previous day's range, our high was at
627 uh07
and our low was at 6158. Excuse me. Our
high was at 62695.
The low was at 6158.
Going over to Edgeful because they have
a report for inside bars. Pull up cues.
Go to the inside bar report. And note
that we have a 74% chance of breaking
out of the previous day's range. We only
have a 26% chance of staying within that
range. Knowing the stat, I'm
automatically targeting either the
upside or the downside for the day. What
I went into the day with was pretty much
no bias. We opened flat. But we had no
upside bias, no downside bias. What I
wanted to do was see if we got either a
previous day's 50 or London 50 retest.
The first one that we got was the London
50. I entered a 3 MNQ long there. That
is going to be this first trade here at
25503.
Previous days 50 lined up pretty much at
25700. London 50 pretty much lined up at
25500.
So, I entered with about a $200 stop
loss on 3M andNQ comes out to about 18
to 20 points somewhere in that range.
I'm not entirely sure. I always set the
stop loss typically at $200. If I'm
taking two to 3 M and Q. If I'm in four,
five, 6 MNQ, the stop loss is usually
about 250, maybe 300. So, that first
trade, if we go on project X here, I
entered at what time was that? Entered
at
9:34. So four minutes after the open.
Where is our open here? Waited for that
London retest. London 50 retest. We got
it perfectly. Had the stop loss in place
at 200. We wicked down 25488.
Wasn't really all that close to the stop
loss. And then we managed to catch a
beautiful reversal. The target on this
trade was the London high. I trailed the
stop loss up as the trade goes up. And
what I do with my stop losses is I like
to trail them $100, $200 behind wherever
the profit is. So if I'm up $400, I like
to have the stop loss at either 200 if I
want it to be a little looser or 300 if
I want it to be a little tighter. As
soon as the trade got up to $100 profit
or 150 in this case, because it was an
opening trade, I moved the stop loss to
break even, making a risk-free trade. I
did get wicked out a little early on it
unfortunately. The full TP would have
been $500. I ended up getting 303 profit
out of it.
The trade peaked at about $480 while I
was in it. I trailed the stop loss up to
300 and I got stopped out at 300. The
second trade that we had and what I was
targeting was a retest of that previous
day's 50. Going back over to the QQQ
chart and we'll go into replay mode
here.
There is our 945 candle. What I wanted
was a retest back down. I do want to
continue in the uptrend because 80% of
the time when price is trending in one
direction, it will continue to do so.
Only 20% of the time it pivots. So, what
I wanted to do to rejoin that upside was
wait for a retest down to previous days
50. And then my target was pretty much
just that equal high. And the reason
that we are targeting the equal high is
because going over to Edgeville yet
again, we go to QQQ, we go to the
initial bounce breakout and we note the
stats that say going over to the buy
rejection report on the initial bounce.
We note the stats that say when the low
or high is formed first, this is the
outcome of the high or low being taken
first. In this case, we formed the low
first today. So, we had a 82% chance of
going and taking the high. That is why I
was looking for a retest or a TP of that
equal high. Going into replay mode yet
again. Let's see what that next candle
did. And we had a perfect retest back
down to that previous day's 50. I mean,
this one could not have been any better.
My entry was right there at previous
days 50. My TP was set to equal highs.
As you can see, we did make a wick
higher on this one. That being my new TP
of the trade. The next candle,
we had a beautiful continuation all the
way up to that equal high. Now,
unfortunately, I did trail a stop loss a
little too close on this one. Ended up
getting stopped out at $50 profit. The
trade ended up going another 50 points
for $320
profit, I believe. Is what it is. I'm
happier complaining about the profit
that I could have made as opposed to
being a little greedy having the trade
be up 200 bucks and then being ticked
out 200 in the red. Yet again at 1011
what I did was enter on a retest of that
previous day's 50 as well as note that
IB stat again. The IB stat either the
high or the low is formed first. you
typically go and target the high or the
low breakout.
Yet again, we form the low. So, we're
targeting the high with an 82% chance of
going and breaking the high.
Going down to the five minute just to
show it a little bit better.
There is our retest at 10:105
in that range. I entered had a $200 stop
loss on this. This one I did get very
lucky with. The stop loss missed by half
a point. 0.5 or two ticks and then it
ended up going and hitting the full TP.
Yet again, I trailed the stop loss a
little too quick. Whether I got unlucky
with the wicks that we were having today
or I just trailed the stop loss a little
too fast. The trade was up 200. I moved
the stop loss to 100 green. Ended up
getting ticked out at 100 green before
it ended up going and taking the full
TP. That's just the straight the trading
strategy that I go about. I'm not too
upset if I miss out on profit. I'd
rather be missing profit than being red
on the day. Those are the three trades I
had today. Those are as simple as it
gets. I mean, you do not get much more
simple than that. Just looking at
previous days 50 and London 50 for
entries. Now, after we broke that
initial bounce,
we broke over previous days 50, we broke
London 50. Note what I added about the
inside bar stat. We go over to Q's. We
note the inside bar stat that we have a
74% 73.8% chance of breaking the high or
low of the previous day's range because
we opened within that range. Obviously,
today we did not quite get to that high,
but we got pretty damn close. What this
might indicate is that this is a draw or
a level that we should kind of gravitate
towards.
Lining up with the initial balance
breakout as well. We typically have half
to one full standard deviation move
after the initial balance is broken. We
went up to half a standard deviation,
couldn't quite get enough momentum to go
up to one, and then ended up kind of
fizzling out for the rest of the day.
I typically end my trading day after the
initial balance is broken simply because
the half and one and 1.5 standard
deviation moves, they don't happen all
that often. We usually just go to half a
standard deviation. Anything past that,
you're just lucky. or there's news that
comes out with it. They have very low
statistics.
After that initial bounce broke, I was
happy with the day. We ended the day up.
If we go to the stats here, ended the
day at 453.
Yesterday, we had a phenomenal day. Day
before that,
about in line with what I usually do.
Had a blow up day last Thursday. It
happens. The goal of this account is to
just buy one EVAL, get that eval passed,
get a payout, use the payout from that
eval to fund another four accounts, and
then copy trade all five to get five
payouts on all accounts.
I'm going to try to get some more of
these trade recap videos out. They're
very simple to do. The trading concept
is very simple. Well, as you can see, we
just had three beautiful I mean, they
were p picture perfect trades that we
had today off London 50, previous days
50. Everything lined up. We had that
inside bar stat we were looking at. We
had the initial bar, our initial balance
breakout. Beautiful trading day today.
Thank you guys for stopping by. Hope you
enjoyed the video. Drop a sub, drop a
like. I'll try to get some more of these
videos out. As I just said, enjoy the
rest of your day. Peace out.